man accused of murdering four University
of Idaho students is due to enter a plea
in court this morning a grand jury
indicted Brian coburger last week on
four counts of first-degree murder and
one count of burglary and prosecutors
are accusing the 28 year old of breaking
into an off-campus house and stabbing
four people to death including Kaylee
Gonzalez six months ago Lilia Luciano
has more now from the Gonzalez family
who spoke to 48 hours last week about
the case she is at the courthouse now in
Moscow Idaho for us Lilia good morning
hey Tony good morning in just a few
hours the accused killer is expected to
enter into that courthouse and plead not
guilty also several of the family
members of at least one of the victims
will also be there they say they hope
today marks the first step in some
semblance of justice for their murdered
children
after more than four months Brian
coburger will again face an Idaho judge
to answer for allegedly killing four
University of Idaho students he knows
you know what he did to our daughter the
family of 21 year old victim Kaylee
Gonzalez plans to be there her parents
Christy and Stephen Gonzalez spoke to 48
hours he's going to feel all of us just
staring at the back of his head because
he won't even turn around
prosecutors accuse him of entering an
off-campus home in the early morning
hours of November 13th last year where
he allegedly stabbed Gonzales Madison
Mogan zaneker nodal and Ethan Chapin
multiple times with a large
military-style knife it was likely all
four victims who were asleep during the
attack
nearly seven weeks after the killings
police arrested the suspect at his
family's home in eastern Pennsylvania
among the evidence prosecutors have
cited are traces of DNA matching him
from a knife sheath like this one at the
crime scene and also surveillance
footage of a vehicle repeatedly driving
past the student's home the night of the
murders the car a white sedan similar to
one co-berger owned
at the time of the killings he was a PhD
criminology student at Washington State
University living in Pullman Washington
about a 15-minute drive from the crime
scene the big question here of course is
motive CBS News legal contributor
Jessica Levinson says that despite there
being strong evidence for the
prosecution the absence of a murder
weapon at the scene and the lack of a
clear motive could strengthen any
defense having a defendant who is at
least ostensibly an expert in the
criminal justice system does add an
additional layer it will be really
interesting to see if the prosecution
would use that to argue he knew exactly
what he was doing meanwhile the College
Community is still recovering from the
shocking loss
last weekend the University of Idaho
awarded posthumous degrees to the
seniors Mogan and Gonzalez what do you
hope will happen
that he he will be put to death
like an animal like he is
it is unlikely that co-burger will be
offered a plea deal today of course
there is many details that we hope to
learn from the case but one thing that
we're hearing from experts is that the
trial will not begin for at least six
months to even a year so a long road
ahead for those families Nate
right about that Lilia thank you ahead
Brittany Grant